there's one thing you're probably not
training that can drastically improve
your jump height your running speed and
your general athleticism that one thing
is ankle stiffness now this might sound
like a bad thing like something you
wouldn't want but in fact ankle
stiffness is a very positive thing for
athletes and we're going to explain why
in this video but first i'm going to
demonstrate how important it is by
jumping over this bin and I'm going to
do it in such a way that I'm barely
bending my legs I slept on the with my
son last night and very achy and this
grass is squishy and slippery what could
possibly go wrong now watch carefully
friends because the devil is very much
in the details as I'm jumping I'm not
bending my leg at any point rather I'm
just taking off from running this kind
of goes against what we intuitively
assume about jumping so what's going on
here what am I talking about what is
ankle stiffness well ankle stiffness
basically refers to the strength of your
angle tendon its ability to return
energy to the ground and this is much
more important than most people think so
if I told you I wanted you to train in
order to be able to jump over railings
and dust bins you might do that by doing
heavy heavy squats and this makes sense
it's been shown in studies to
definitively improve jump height this is
normally measured as a static jump with
a counter movement where you drop down
into a deep Squat and then launch up in
the air a vertical jump this isn't
actually how we jump when we're playing
sports or doing something like parkour
where you're usually running and moving
at the time of jumping in that scenario
you normally jump from a running
position so you're usually jumping from
one leg and you normally have very
minimal contact time with the ground you
place your foot down and launch yourself
up in the air there's no amortization
phase you're not dropping deep down into
a squat and then jumping up that's not
how people dunk and therefore doing
heavy heavy squats is going to have
limited transfer to this kind of
performance and that's why we need to
focus on something else ankle stiffness
it's not about generating power it's
about your ability to trans F power from
a run into a jump this is something that
JC Santana pointed out to me by slowing
down videos and showing me how the
athletes actually performed the same
thing goes when you're sprinting studies
actually show that when sprinting
there's actually far less plantar
flexion and dorsiflexion than you might
think your feet stay relatively static
instead of actually pushing off the
ground they're more bouncing off the
ground you're running like you're on
blades so again ankle stiffness is
really important here to train this we
need to train the tendons to make them
stronger and stiffer but at the same
time we also need to train the carves
this is essentially a isometric
contraction for the carves where they're
trying to hold the joint in place so
that the tendon can rebound and return
that energy what this doesn't mean is
avoiding any kind of ankle Mobility
training because mobility and this kind
of stiffness ankle hysteresis those are
separate things so now you might be
wondering what specifically can you do
to train your ankle stiffness and well
done you're asking the right questions
there's a few exercises the one that JC
Santana himself self recommends is the
truck push so go and find a parking lot
and a big heavy truck he actually made a
video on this channel about that so this
is a great workout it's concentric only
meaning it isn't that fatiguing it's
something that nearly anyone can do even
if they have Mobility or joint problems
it's a great overlooked form of training
that can replace a squat for many people
and actually have more benefits through
athleticism you can do the same thing
with your car if you make sure to find a
nice quiet track somewhere and have
someone sitting in the driving seat to
steer don't do it without that because
that can go wrong I once actually pushed
my car bit on a hill and then had to
chase after it and it very nearly ended
badly for me and my wife would have
killed me of course if you have a sled
at your gym then you can push or pull
that and that will work equally well
this is also a lovely short range
movement relatively low impact what
you're doing is getting lots and lots of
blood flowing to those tendons because
tendons have a lesser blood supply than
muscle this is a great way to fortify
them and it's what the athletic truth
group and Ben Patrick talk about all the
time so so many reasons to do truck
pushing sled
pushing an alternative is jump rope now
jump rope is a fantastic tool used by
many athletes particularly boxers
primarily as a form of cardio jump rope
is fantastic cardio of course but it's
also great for staying light on your
feet it's great for your hand ey
coordination and even better it builds
ankle stiffness so you can build the
ankle stiffness and rebound into the
ground for sprinting for jumping and see
great improvements in this area and
today's video just so happens to be
sponsored by crossrope cross rope make
what are in my opinion the very best
quality jump ropes they're made from a
proprietary material that is not only
really durable but doesn't tangle when
you leave it on the ground and that
feels nice and weighty as it goes round
the best part though is that the ropes
are also weighted so you can choose to
have a nice light rope if you want to
practice fast jump rope and or you can
use a heavier one if you want to get an
even more full body workout train those
shoulders as well and actually get your
heart rate higher and burn more calories
even more quickly you can clip these in
and out extremely easily which is a
great feature and you can even track
your progress on the app especially if
you get the amp handles which actually
track the number of jumps you do cross
RP also offers a 60-day trial period a
return window where if you don't like
the ropes you can return them with no
questions asked so there's no risk at
all if you want to give cross rope a go
yourself then viewers of the channel can
get 15% off her jump rope by using code
bioner and now on with the
show another option is one of my
favorite exercises the 100 up or high
knees high knee so basically what you're
going to do here is you're going to
stand on the spot and you're going to
run bringing your knees up nice and high
start off nice and gently because this
can be quite a big impact on the ankles
but over time you can turn this into
more of a Sprint it's a fantastic way to
get yourself really gassed out really
quickly it's something you can do
anywhere it's great for your hip
stability but of course it's also great
for that ankle stiffness you got bunny
hops where you're bouncing on the ground
this is great for getting springiness
all through your lower body and then of
course you can just Sprint sprinting of
course is great for ankle stiffness and
then you've got other options like Hill
Sprints which are not only lower impact
not only more of a challenge with more
resistance but also actually put your
ankles into more of a stretch position
as you're performing the exercise or you
can use bounds where you're sprinting
but taking the biggest possible jump
with each step making it into an even
more bouncy and explosive form of
movement this is just a few examples to
get started with I will say take it
gentle to start with because this can be
quite a lot of impact if your ankles
aren't used to it that's the whole point
build up to that get used to it then
eventually you're going to be less
likely to injure your ankle and far
better at exploding off the ground
sprinting jumping and all that good
stuff let me know in the comments down
below if ankle stiffness is something
you already trained if it's something
you're going to consider training now
and what else you'd like me to cover in
future if you want a training program
that takes care of things like ankle
stiffness as well as Mobility conative
performance strength everything else
rotational strength all the stuff that's
usually missed then check out my ebook
and training program super functional
training 2.0 there's a link in the
description down below and it's on
discount for the rest of January either
way guys thank you so much for watching
this one and I'll see you next time bye
for
[Music]
now